à la seule annonce de leur nom le public
est déjà en ébullition
une entrée en matière qui en dit long
sur ce qui va suivre pendant plus de 20
minutes la température kotéba caf est va
monter monter encore monter en pression
le collectif de dj tmp et dj paille ou
tous les trois en position pour faire de
ce jour une prestation unique en son
genre
duguay
vraiment ordinaire fallait vraiment
formidable
[Applaudissements]
et musique festive à la baston qu'on
aime la fête
normalement des plats sucrés moi j'aime
ça tue c'est de partager l'énergie que
quand je n'arrive tout le monde et les
jo répondre présent je suis content aux
platines lui c'est dj amigo soca
dancehall reggae il enchaîne les styles
avec minutie précision et poli un
cocktail molotov qui ne laisse aucun
festivaliers indifférents spécialement
pour l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
la pénitence annonce l'innovation avec
pour moi j'écoute ça depuis rencontre et
puis comme il faut faire la différence
se démarquer des autres laissé son
empreinte pour cette sixième édition du
panaf est des danseuses rythme les
transitions d'un seul
et au moment où on s'y attend le moins
le show prend une autre dimension dans
ce type de configuration forme et du
contenu c'est pas simplement voix et la
musique qu'on veuille la musique ou
mixer il faut avoir une présence
continue le couple est qu'à laval comme
seychelles mouvements de danse
les danseurs ont pas bref tout le monde
en tout cas tous les éléments autour
c'est quelque chose c'est à continuer
c'est un ensemble qui fait que sa furia
prépare à ça se fait durant ce week-end
de fête sur les 200 que comptait le
festival mais d'une vingtaine de dj
d'ici et d'ailleurs auront chacun leur
manière su conquérir le public marne